[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb we got a very special
episode I've been wanting to get um well
I've been wanting to get Canon Reeves on
the show for a long time I worked with
him a long time ago I love him who
doesn't love Canon Reeves but what's
awesome is I met two guys one of which I
had met a long time ago uh Brett and Rob
who are in this band dog start with Koo
and I enjoyed it
immensely you know at first just like I
just want Keo on the show I want Keo
show and they like well hey you know dog
star would like to be on and there's
this band that I listened to you know in
the '90s and then they had broken up and
then these guys got back together and
there's so many great stories and you
know we get into the mental health
aspect and really fun and insightful and
I I fell in love with the other two guys
I mean I was already in love with keeno
I had a great time Bryce I truly had a a
great time and I think it comes across
um and you know it's also good it's
their their music I like their music
it's it's not like I'm sitting there
going oh gosh here we go I got to you
know if it was metal stuff you know real
hard metal I'd be like oh yeah the metal
I wouldn't know what to say but it was
music you get into some of the songs off
their new album somewhere between the
power lines and palm trees maybe the
flip of it yeah so if you haven't
listened to that before you listen to
this check that out because they get
into some of the songs yeah follow us at
inside of you podcast on Instagram and
Facebook inside you pod on the Twitter
you could watch on YouTube write a
review if you liked it it certainly
helps the podcast and if you want to
join patreon to support the podcast we
could use your help patreon.com inside
you let you know if you go to my
Instagram at the Michel rosenbom link
tree Cameo U my live podcast with
Kristen Ritter is coming up January 24th
get tickets at the region theater
Kristen Ritter um Breaking Bad the be in
apartment 23 Jessica Jones Jessica Jones
just tons of stuff great actress great
friend of mine and also our uh are
inside of you online store which you can
get tons of cool merch lexith scripts
tons of Smallville stuff and cool
tumblers and whatnot and uh yeah Bryce
it's good to have you here anything else
no just uh this is the final episode of
the year and then final episode of the
year is it really uhhuh we did it yep
final episode but let me tell you
something next episode next episode's a
big one there's a lot of big ones coming
up subscribe uh enjoy have a Wonder ful
holiday um be good to yourself and let's
get into this podcast let's get inside
of dog star it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with Michael
Rosen
[Music]
bomb inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience this isn't your man kid
no this is this is the the podcast room
I'm I have an affinity for horror movie
uh movies and um so it's you know I
always ask guests like do you have
anything signed or any memorabilia and
the answer usually is no so I'm guessing
Pio you don't have any I not really I
got a couple of things well I mean I see
you have a poster of
Dracula and he signed it Gary signed it
amazing oh that's not blood I have AAR
crossed oceans of time to find you find
you that's good so remarkable I mean
it's so I gave Francis Ford copela once
for his birthday some
mushrooms what and then uh yeah yes this
is great while we were doing
Dracula wait before you he directed it
or after no no I think it was it was a I
I know it was during it was I heard it
was his birthday and I happened to have
an eth of some mushrooms and so I gave
them to
him and how did he react he took them I
don't want to he had a very nice
birthday wow he said he said he enjoyed
them that's why Roman directed the first
five minutes I think no Roman was doing
all the experimental not experimental
but Dad I got this just go over there
and wow you gave mushrooms to one of the
biggest directors of all time I heard
that Gary Oldman didn't get along by the
way with with him no no they got along
did they they did so after he did the
mushrooms he did the apocalypse recut he
did he did the red he's like wait a
minute well no Somebody went up to much
they were interviewing him I remember I
had the laser disc and they said to him
hey uh what's your relationship like
with FR Francis for C was like when you
you're dealing with in a relationship
like this you know in a business like
this you've got to have a great ego and
Francis for Copa has an ego the size of
San Francisco and I've got a pretty big
one
too I was like yeah yeah so it's was
like two egos but they probably two
let's not call them egos I mean they're
great profound artist that's right true
that was a good sit in Nancy you almost
had i f was it yeah I felt like that was
a good sit I love that movie yeah
everything Gary does Gary's the best is
the best but this isn't about Gary
Oldman this is about dog star this is a
long time coming I've been playing when
you walked in I was a little embarrassed
because I didn't mean to have your music
playing around my house you were going
to do an interview so we appreciate you
taking the time to listen to the work
that we've created back in the day you
guys toured with David Bowie well we
didn't tour we had a show well a show
but you toured with Bon Jo yeah in in
Australia and New Zealand and I I keep
thinking how did you not just want to
like were you crawling out of your skin
with nerves like how how do you do that
how do you open for John Bon Joi well
when you open for John Bon joovy and
your dog star you go on when it's still
light out and it's the the
afternoon and it's you and a handful of
people in the sunshine couple mostly
vendors and some vendors walking around
so you know it's kind of chill you're
down you're kind of like the third you
know you're the opener before the opener
and but they were great to us and it was
a great experience but yeah we played in
front of a handful of people I mean
nerves are good it's nerves are
different than um like fear that's
different nerves are more like
excitement and well my nerves are fear
okay that's different my my nerves are
fear too Brett what are your nerves I
just pretended there was no cameras
there a version of like everyone's naked
my nerves are excitement usually unless
I don't know the
song I'm not kiding mine are usually
based I had this conversation with my
psychiatrist before I interviewed you
guys and I was like my when I get
nervous goes well it's good everybody
has nerves it's this is I go no no I I
need something for this because it can
be crippling sometimes sometimes it's
and it's all fear it's all fear-based
failure looking like an idiot but do you
find um like an acting like if you're
really prepared like you still get the
nerve but it's it's a different kind of
nerve because it's like you you feel
good if you I feel like if you're not
prepared then it's becomes a whole
another set of nerve it's a nerve of
like oh I didn't prepare enough and then
I'm afraid of that more so than like oh
I'm just nervous cuz there's all these
people I'm on Jimmy Kimmel which which I
think is smart I think if you're not
nervous you're dead almost you're not
alive like it's just electricity so the
thing is how you Channel those right and
I think was being with these two guys
helps me helps a lot because they're
they can be calming too you know just
being with these two guys so really you
guys are that calming cuz right now I
feel they help me a lot well I sense
like this no Robert's the calming
one is he really yeah why why is Rob
calming he's like hey man you know just
play the song play the show just focus
on the song well what you what are you
saying before he says that are you
saying I'm like oh what the [__] I'm
going to [__] fail and what the [__]
is all wrong and I don't know what if I
don't remember and oh my gosh and like
yeah even when I'm prepared I get nerves
but he's like man just Play the
song yeah what the [__] man I guess
that's just wisdom Rob not me yeah Rob
not BR you don't get nervous for often
do you I do I do and you're singing now
I get nervous when the when there's a
newer song that I don't have locked in
yet and we're going to go perform it and
I'm like maybe I got the lyrics maybe I
don't here we go we'll see so that that
part is nerve-wracking but yeah when
you're well rehearsed then you get to
focus more on like the audience and the
other band members and have fun with it
yeah so IDE we're well rehearsed in the
nerves are minimum I just want to know
how you could be so successful
being fear-based like your nerves are
fear like I I mean that's just but it's
gotten you through it You' gotten
through
it
yeah
yeah I mean yeah I mean yeah I wish I
could be other people where it wasn't
fear I wish I could do that but maybe
that's just how we're wired I mean we're
talking about degrees too right there's
you know more you're sometimes more
nervous it's not necessarily
catastrophic nervosity right every time
it's you
know this show is sponsored by better
help better help online therapy do not
fast forward because this is something
that truly helps so many people around
the world so many of my friends um you
hear the guests how many guests talk
about therapy and it's just it's amazing
and a lot of people I talk about how you
know a family member who you you know no
one will understand me no one knows what
I've been through well that's not true
there's so many people that do know what
you're going through and and um they've
seen it all and therapy really truly
helps it helps me and whether or not
your family gives gifts during the
holidays you can always give yourself
the gift of a healthier you whether by
starting therapy going easier on
yourself in tough moments or treating
yourself to a day of complete rest
remember to give yourself some love this
holiday season this time of year can be
a lot it's hectic it's stressful it's
really easy to forget to take time for
yourself but you deserve it as much as
your loved ones do and it's super
convenient with better help it's
entirely online and designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule even during the holidays just
fill out a brief questionnaire this
thing takes no time at all to get
matched with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge so if you're not
vibing with your therapist don't think
oh it's not working no just switch to
another therapist and feel the Vibes
feel good about who you're talking to
you feel uh comfortable and you will
find that with better help in the season
of giving give yourself what you need
with better help visit betterhelp.com
insid toay to get 10% off your first
month that's better help
hp.com inside inside of you is brought
to you by discover if you like using
debit over credit don't you think it's
time you also get rewarded well now you
can with Discover cash back debit it's a
checking account that rewards everyone
with cash back on everyday purchases
plus there are no fees period we're
talking date nights thrifting the latest
trends nights out with your friends and
it's now earning you cash back with
discover cashback debit check out
eligibility in terms at discover.com
slashback deit discover Bank member
FDIC it's also when you're on the road I
find there's so much going on and
there's like the morning is the routine
and then if you get hit up with
something like a Jimmy Kimmel when
you're out in the middle of the road you
have less time to be nervous like
sometimes time can be your enemy or or
just being having too much of that weird
sort of down I think a lot of actors
will say like sitting in the trailer too
long it's like and then they call for
you like now and like well wait a minute
you know I've been here for 4 hours and
then but we want it now right and that
think it's it's when you're on the road
with this with these guys I feel like
you get into this like Rhythm and you
don't have time for that you are calming
on this particular you are [__]
calming it's his voice and the way he
just is there's some kind of uh
optimistic feeling you get when when
you're just talking it's like
everything's going to be all right do
you feel Brett you don't always agree
with
that he's like well you know he could
you know sure you guys bang heads I just
sit back and let it be um no
it's I agree with Rob in the sense that
yeah if you if you overthink it then
that's where the wheels come off so I
think like yesterday we did we did a
rehearsal and it was great and then we
we recorded a pass and it was oh cool
and then you guys want to do it again
and then it's like oh okay now we're
thinking and then we sucked yeah so I
was like oh let's just use that first
one because why did we even do the
second one we're thinking right I mean I
think we're in our head and going
absolutely thinking to but when you just
come out and bang done and it's like
okay and that becomes a little more
second nature right yeah second you
start getting cerebral then it's like
look out yeah I get it well enough about
nerves we can get into nerves at another
time but you know I I start thinking
about you guys were together well you
know for how long for 20 something years
before you
stopped yeah 10 maybe yeah around 10
years and then what was it was was there
an event was there something that
sparked hey let's do this again in our
50s or whatever because you know it's
it's it's it's like what was it some
sort of excitement something like hey we
have more to do here no but eventually
yes I mean was but yes maybe I don't
know I can't speak for I don't know I
mean I know that we love playing and we
and all the within those years we did
get together and in you know my home and
and
play in the in the studios you know
right keo's had a rig there that never
left I mean it just it was just always
there so and um so we did get together
we got together I look back and you know
videos and stuff there's like 2011 I see
that we were there and you know you know
your iPhone has dates I'm like oh [__]
we were there in 2011 and then certain
times 2015 so we did sort of bomb in and
get together but I guess we made a
conscious decision to try to do
something um sort of right around after
the pandemic there we were up at up at
the Matrix Premiere in San Francisco and
we as Brett was saying we had a
conversation about gear or something and
we kind of nerded out about that and and
we just I don't know the timing just
sort of came together and we just we got
together and played and it just sounded
good let's give it a try yeah yeah I I
guess so it's like I guess you don't
know what you're getting into until you
just get into it yeah and Brett was
living in San Francisco at the time so
he came down and
me and um I think it was great to sort
of it was sort of like you know that
Beatles Movie World all they all sleep
in the same was it a hard days tonight
or help help where they're all like
sleeping in that living room and those
beds like sunken beds it kind of felt
like that you know we get up and have
breakfast together and then K would come
over spend eight hours and we we kind of
did Camp it was like Camp right and then
I don't know how it happened but we came
up with 12 songs I honestly and how long
10 minutes no how long that we had more
than 12 songs right 15 I think but how
long was that couple two weeks or three
weeks um probably if you're looking
about talking about days spent probably
what 21 days overall Jesus three
different sessions of look how prolific
eight days gone for a month come back
another eight days kind of thing and
what do you send voice memos to each
other you have an idea for a song you
want you guys send it no it was all done
in the same room candy grams we sent
each candy there was nothing really
other than you know can a bass riff or
something he would bring that in but
there was really no no writing done
singularly I don't think on this one it
was just kind
of I have this idea or you know Rob
would just start playing a beat and then
we just look at each other and go we
recorded everything so we got lucky we
caught every every little moment every
the entire session yeah everything we
did we record whenever we liked
something we like when we were on to
something oh go it's like that's a lot
of hours to go through no no uh who's
the one out of the three you that
usually doesn't like stuff as much as
the others who's more
critical probably Rob Rob yeah and what
will does he kind of [__] foot around
it does he kind of go like yeah he sits
in his throne and he looks down with his
good judgment and says that is not what
you should be doing I don't like that I
don't buy it at all I don't think you
guys are screwing up whatever you good
you started to work on definitely the
the Keel of the of the boat right there
yeah we're sometimes we we get like note
nerds and we're like o Play The A over
the e oh wait let me try the F SHP over
your D Rob's like what are you doing
you're wrecking this song like leave it
alone it was good before you guys it was
good before so yeah but we wouldn't try
this he's like no just don't like yeah
you know it's been around for thousands
of years
Thomson nursery rhymes yes you know I
think I you these guys are so talented
and they do that they'll play different
T notes and tunings and things over
things and sometimes it works it usually
it works great and um and having Brett
in the band it's almost like two guitar
players it sounds to me like sometimes I
close my eyes I'm and I'm because plays
in Stereo yeah and I feel like who's the
other guitar player and I look up oh
it's just one guy and I noticed that in
the Kimmel last night the production of
that and the way the spread was and and
even when Keo the bass sounded so good
and it just sounded more it sounded so
good and it's a tribute to these guys
because they uh you know they just they
have the right gear they're really they
really into the sonics of it all and I
think that's kept us a three-piece you
know we tried to play with other
musicians and we have and even when we
did the Greek Theater thing with these
other musicians and it was lovely and
everything but there was something about
being in a three-piece that's really
satisfying you know did you think that
when you guys took that sort of Hiatus
even though you were kind of playing
here and there together do you think
that well by yourself did you I know you
learned harmonica right no a little bit
yeah I don't you play it live yeah so
that's that's would be yeah well that's
more than a little bit Yeah but like did
you guys were you K were you uh playing
bass by yourself to just songs and [__]
like the time yeah I have a base hanging
around so I like doing little diddies do
you like in doing it in front of people
or just by yourself
um that s why are you so J this is
called inside of you I like doing
some I was being do you like uh doing it
in the do you play your Bass by yourself
do you go to the
mall Sherman Oaks or Beverly Center what
do you usually wear when you play Bas by
yourself well you know what I'm saying
like you know I play guitar with myself
for nobody yeah no I'm often times it's
nobody I play alone and do you guys feel
this is a question for three because I
as a musician I what do you get from it
do you feel like there's a there's
purpose in playing music or is it just a
passion or something you just love like
what is it exactly Rob start I want I
want to hear it I mean I play a lot of
piano so it's hard to play drums by
herself for more than like 30 minutes
and it gets a little weird you know you
just you just want the other guys with
in the room you know so I'll move to the
piano that I can do forever and and it's
like healing you know it's just a it's
just healing the tones and just it makes
you feel good mean music listening to it
playing it yeah it's the same that
people that don't play and they listen
it's the same thing being a in a
musician it's a little bit different but
I think it's the same tone you know just
that it just makes you
feel filled up you know
Brad use my mic yeah I Feel Jesus he's
my Bas
yeah I think it's just that one of those
few things in the world that allows you
to shut the world out you know it's for
me at least it's you know when you're
playing a three-minute song or whatever
it is or sometimes just listening to
music but when you're playing I don't
know if it's because you're using your
brain focusing on the guitar and the
singing or whatever it is but the world
as you know it just goes away you're not
thinking about anything else you know
even if sometimes if you're sick or
whatever you can still play and have
that couple minutes where nothing exists
except the feeling like Rob said of that
you know I agree so it's really it's
really fun and then the song's over and
then you're like let's start another one
quick do you ever play play while you're
playing like you're playing a song just
say you're by yourself and then all of a
sudden you're listening to what yourself
soon but you don't want to be taken away
from it to distract you but yet the act
of just listening to what you're doing
can sort of make you go into a different
mode or something like oh you know it's
not like oh I'm I'm you know just just
the T the tones of the guitar does that
ever distract you I have a problem where
I'm playing and all of a sudden I'm like
oh this is good and then I [__] it up
completely you become a fan stop
thinking it's good just just keep being
yeah how do you do that I don't know
like do you ever happen in when you know
you have like a they call it like a
happening when something oh yeah very
rare no it is you know what I'm talking
about when you actually feel like it's
not planned it's just oh my God God but
if that happened all the time I'd be
Hopkins right you know so it's something
that I I wish happened all the time but
when it does happen it's like oh man
this is cool and you know it's sort of
ephemeral you know it's it's just like
it is what it is those are the moments I
think those the moment it happens in
music too and and I know I think in
acting maybe it's like you know
improvisation or something but I'm not
talk about jazz or anything but it does
to me it happens in music for Me Maybe
it's easier because I'm listening and
sitting and like sometimes I'll get
carried away listening to like something
like glimmer like BR sings that even
Dylan street because the lyrics and it
gets me a little sad I listen to that I
sort of get taken away I'm like you said
like K said like oh [__] or Brett said
that don't don't go off the train right
especially when you're playing for
people like you can do that if you get
into you don't almost want to be more
robot how do you stay that fine line
like I got to be Pro but then I but I
want to have it happening but then I
don't want to go off the train and like
go off into some I think it just can
what do you think does it take you away
from like everything else um certainly
yeah uh so much about music yeah love
being transported listening to
music um and I love writing songs I love
the creative aspect of it um the sense
of play I love um when you connect when
the three of us connect connect finding
something oh we like that building it um
in the Journey of it becoming a song and
I I love that moment uh love the
fraternity of the band that um I love
playing live that's that's good clean
fun um but yeah I mean music is Mana
from heaven right it sustains us it
helps us share with each other it helps
us
commune yeah I always think about that I
always think like music to me is I I I
don't know what I would do without it
there's a lot of things you could do
without obviously you have to eat but
like music there's always something in
my head there's always something I'm
humming I'm singing I I crave for you
know and it's just like and if it's not
there it's it's it feels like it's
missing did you guys find that like
that's maybe that's what brought you
back you know it was sort of that
missing each other missing the music
missing all these things these elements
that deep down you knew you really loved
yeah and for me personally yes missed it
but also can only get that playing with
Robert and Brett like that was the one
thing was unique like yeah the chemistry
ass yeah the chemist chemistry of this
band is a is very strong for only three
guys yeah yeah cuz I I had a band and uh
we just it just it was bad like I love
these guys but it it like for a while it
kind of ruined our friendship it just
was like you know two guys always wanted
to get stoned all the time and it just
it just got kind of and it was like [__]
I could see how it could be crippling
you always hear about bands every band
has their drama but I'm looking at you
guys now maybe it's history maybe it's
like you know you've done the whole uh
Lava Lounge and uh Crazy Girls after
working in the studio all night Kenny
Funk filled me in on some 30 years ago
[__] oh my gosh but you know in general
it's like you sort of I hate to say the
word but like grown up or just gotten to
a certain place where the [__] isn't
important these these three band members
have always had a really good work ethic
so even in the the earlier days as you
were speaking of we still showed up and
did the work that needed to be done so a
lot of other bands I was in before I met
these guys not so much kind of stories
like what you were just talking about
like God we need to get another bass
player again like they're okay dude
flamed out okay like um he's ruining the
vibe okay so um a lot of that was like
yeah you said you know just people
showing up late or just being generally
bad personalities or just whatever you
know it's hard to be in a band it's so
intimate yeah so um and I love these
guys it's hard like stopping you know
quitting the band I that was like the
most stress I've ever most therapy I've
ever been in was leaving the band yeah
that no one knew
you know what I mean well it's a it's a
partnership I guess right so you have to
have mutual respect for each other and
your time and your you know if we're all
here then let's do this let's not waste
each other's time kind of thing so we've
always been good about that what's your
what's your favorite song on the album
honestly but without just if you had to
pick one song Rob uh you know I mean
we're playing him live so different than
the record because we wrote him so quick
and record them so quick but I know I do
I love glimmer and Dylan Street I mean I
love those two songs yeah I said one oh
shoot glimmer Street all right all right
BR uh changes for me but right now I'm
I'm feeling uh how the story ends yeah
that's where I'm too how the story ends
yeah love the chorus and how the story
is I love uh lust that guitar okay so of
all the interviews we've done and of
everything this is the first mention of
lust are you serious isn't that great I
I was waiting for this to happen it's
the first time dude how can not anybody
not talk about L the first time
someone's even mentioned told you I said
no one's ever even and I love that sort
of nutty kind of and that music was the
first thing we wrote for this album that
opening guitar riff was something that
was like I believe the first thing we
worked on Wow like that yeah that rhythm
of you know that I don't know if it's a
cury kind of whatever it is but does
this song make people uncomfortable why
are they why is this being avoided so
much like it's got an interesting thing
it ends weird it's not it's not your
classic like pop nugget right it doesn't
resolves goes in another kind of reject
not rejection Direction I I love that
song I love the break to that SAR Indian
style like it's exciting it feels like
you're just driving 90 miles an hour and
you're just kind of feeling good and the
air is blowing on your face and you're
just like you got to you're going to
meet some hot lady in the video you
don't know there's a can I be the guy
driving yes I don't want to be the hot
lady again the guy driving that's the
credit you be the hot lady the guy
driving guy driving guy driving um yeah
it's great and look I I I I really
commend you guys for you know when I
heard you have a new album I remember
listening to you guys and I was like oh
these guys are fun and I remember seeing
you many years ago and this just sounds
to me like it's a just another level of
um it just seems like it just
synchronicity I don't know what the word
is what is the word it's it's just like
the album just is smooth it's almost
like well I think one of the things we
didn't know going into it but then going
through the process of of making the
album with the producer Dave
trumo um it kind of while we were
working on the and we I think we're
feeling it during the set too when we
play it live that there's somehow how a
story like it's not a it's not like a a
um what would be like a concept album
but it feels like there's a kind of
continuity of a story kind of being told
like a through line like a through line
to the whole experience of listening to
the to all of the songs in their
order um and I think one thing I really
like about this band is the variety of
genre in a way you know it's not like
every song it's like what I say it's
like doesn't have same song syndrome I
feel like you can hear that's not just
every song's a pop song and I don't know
it feels like there's a nice kind of
yeah I agree band wit like there's
different feeling songs it just doesn't
go boom it just kind of comes in and out
and waves and it just takes you down for
a minute and it's like yeah and then
comes back up you know you go from like
a song like glimmer to a song like
breach you know or lust in going to
Dylan Street yeah you know those are all
different kind of feelings what uh moods
moods moods who came up come on be
honest who came up with somewhere
between the power lines and palm trees I
think Brett did yeah I was like it's a
long title but I think how did it come
out of your
mouth uh that didn't sound
right
yes better than how did it go into your
mouth that playing bass with G here we
go um here we go I was renting a house
over in I think it was Silver Lake Los V
area and while we were it was the ivanho
reservoir record Rowena Rena Rowena
Reservoir yes so when I'd walk out of
the out of the house to go over to the
studio with these
guys um it was kind of up elevated up
about 35 ft up above street level and I
would look out over this Reservoir and
all there was was palm trees everywhere
and power lines just going between them
and no water in the reservoir remember
yeah and the whole thing was just super
LA and super like nature versus man and
coexisting and it just I took a picture
of it which is the album cover that is
the picture of it that day I took pict
so somewhere between the beauty and all
the [__] yeah kind of yeah and
there's a couple little birds on the
power line which I love that he got that
that's great little doves I think it
just struck me as like this wow this is
one hell of an LA experience right here
like that I'm having so I went and told
these guys this is a really long title
but what do you think and they both said
yeah right away no I don't know if it
was right away I think we chicked around
a few other things for a while but what
was the worst idea you had smell the
glove oh yeah I don't know we did kind
of go off it pretty quick right I don't
remember having a lot backup tit we
didn't play a lot of the name game yeah
and the rest of the photos and the
insert around the home you know where we
live and recorded everything so it ties
in where he was staying because it was
so all the shots were from that are area
in Silver Lake and more palm trees more
power lines and more birds and just
sunsets and weird streaks of light
coyotes everywhere yeah it was just one
of those kind of things yeah yeah I
would get woken up coyot crazy yeah just
yeah but it was fun it was just see what
happens when you make a coyote sound you
[__] die
man I hear that all the time
I have a recording on my phone of of
like what has to be at least 20 coyotes
freaking out while Sirens are blaring in
the background like that's terrifying I
was like this is this is seriously LA
right where do you hear those two things
at the same time only here so I recorded
that and I'm like one day I'll put that
somewhere or use that in some you can
sample it we'll put it in the next
record hey uh I know you probably told
this story a million times but you two
when you met did you really meet him in
a convenience store or is that a lie no
it's a supermarket oh that's kind of
convenient it
was convenient but a convenient store is
smaller that's true it was conveniently
located convenient and then there super
and was he wearing a hockey jersey a Red
Wings Jersey I was a t-shirt it what
year was this it's one of the rare days
Rob had a shirt on that's true put your
shirt on were you always shirtless I
don't I don't know what was wrong I I I
used to play with that CU I was so we
used to play in these small cot 100 Club
so I end up just not wearing one but
looking back on that I'm like oh man
were you ever
shirtless yeah yeah there was walking
around shirtless in the summer days he
used to ride his Norton shirtless up
Beachwood Canyon just a pair of
sunglasses kind no helmet shirtless yeah
that was good those were the days Daring
Do yeah so you met and like you
approached him yeah and what' you say I
said do you know where there hockey game
and I was like it's 90° out dude there's
no hockey here I wanted to play some
pickup hockey ice yeah man and he didn't
know oh I know no he didn't he did know
yeah where'd you go isoplex pck and
Burbank Burbank and you brought him
there yeah every Tuesday and Thursday
Paul lag Gua had a pickup
game Canadian had a pickup game for many
many years many many years yeah yeah do
you still play no cuz I think you play I
was bummed because it was like I think
you played in the the brookheimer league
years ago never played the Brooker game
I was playing in a couple I was on a
couple of teams during league play and
you play goalie I was a go I was a
goalie I am a goalie you do you miss it
yeah very much would you ever do it
again um yeah I don't know how that
would go but yeah why not just rent the
knees man oh yeah my knees my knees are
bad I'm almost 60 years old are you
really are you guys how old are you rob
78 okay
Brett Brett how old are you 54 Brett's
the baby he's the baby we used to call
him young Brett
domrose Kenny funk that's what Kenny
Funk used to call him really yeah young
BR Doos among other things do that
another pressure to Kenny please huh do
that you you did it no I just saw you do
the Kenny Funk
did I love Kenny nobody gets it except
us I know yeah that's a beautiful thing
yeah he's the best um no one can make
you laugh like Kenny what did what did
it feel like for you guys when you got
on stage for the first time after all so
many years uh was it was it awesome or
was it really scary the wait the first
the first time was that that takes us
right back to the nerves part of the
conversation wait was that the gold
diggers right oh okay that but that was
friends and family closed closed private
still the first time there's 110 people
there friends yeah that's even I agree
we played a private show we wanted to
you know play and so yeah there's just
like for me there's all these worldclass
record producers and guitar players in
the audience there was only like 80
people there and I was like 10 of these
people are people I would really don't
want them to see me play and my neighbor
Danielle lenois was there inway it's a
cool spot from the record producer we
worked with
Dave his place gold diggers we thought
it was going to be like a casual little
just our friends you know and then it
ended up it ended up being all these
like heavy music people oh dude we
played at the hotel Cafe once and all
that's a good sound yeah all our friends
came I've never been that nervous but
our drummer K love him he was so nervous
he as he started his stick just flew out
into the audience he's like [__] were
you there Ryan no Ryan wasn't there but
that sounds great yeah can just start
again he did and everybody kind of
laughed like Hey we're with you man
we're with you it can't get any worse
than it can't get any worse but what's
the worst performance you guys could
remember where you got on stage and the
sound sucked so bad you couldn't get it
together someone might have been drunk
but do you remember one show in
particular this
one no yes the host sucked tried to play
his band we're drunk that's a long not
nothing in this iteration of the um band
in my view wait wasn't there like a ice
rink we once played at a
fair wasn't there a fair show we did the
thing in North Dakota and it was just
smelled like cow poop everywhere
remember that that was fun that was fun
wasn't there like a [__] Pie Contest
and dog star we was like was it I'm
blocking this one out Pie Contest and
dog see this is these are the mushrooms
dog star these are the Francis Ford
copala mushrooms was never fair oh wait
wait I know what you're talking about
that was in Northern California was it
no Midwest thing okay I think it's funny
you don't remember it right the Pie
Contest I don't remember a Pie Contest
we had a gig on this last tour actually
that the sound check took over an hour
which is really unusual oh must have
been terrible couldn't get they couldn't
get it figured out for whatever reason
how pissed were you I wasn't pissed it
was just
are we going to get it figured out
before the doors open you know a more
concerned but the show was okay though
show was okay yeah we just it took maybe
more than an hour and it it was just I
think that we had a couple shows on this
where we had um maybe a sound guy it was
his first day on the job not good not
good yeah now we bring our own sound but
that we're talking about monitors right
you can't
hear yeah it's the worst when you Ian
have you ever had where you just can't
hear you just like
onlys in the old days not this this
since I got the inner ears it's so much
better but pre- inner ear it was rough
you know yeah but we had a gig on this
run where we came out in the first song
and the monitors were off just turned
off and I'm singing and I'm like I don't
hear anything oh [__] all I hear is
drums and a little bit of my guitar amp
over there and I'm like I remember that
did you stop no no I just started waving
my guitar tech down to like pointing
frantically like pointing down and
everything yeah nothing's working that's
I think that was the exact hand signal
oh my God yeah so that but other than
that I don't really remember anything
from I don't remember the Pie Contest
what about uh your uh you have your own
label right you play under your own
label yeah we constructed that because
we were told to construct that but we
don't have but you know Robert keeps
saying we should sign band so I don't
know were you signed no we're not not
signed I'll send you the CD good enough
you want to be on Dylan Street like we
don't really have anybody who works with
us or for us and we have no budget we
but we mean well but we mean well we
mean well you want to you want to I'd
like to be around guys and we can't
really support anything that you do
no but we won't sign you if we don't
believe in you but we'll be encouraging
it sounds better than what we have now
do you like egg salad sandwiches I sure
do okay here we make sure well we might
not yeah do you think you will sign
bands though no no you don't want to do
that who us what why we don't know
anything what are we going to help you
with you know probably just as much as a
lot of folks out there and you just let
Rob Rob looks like that was disingenuous
yes Robert could run it talk to Robert
no the cube yeah yeah no I don't so who
deals with all this stuff now that you
have your we have really good management
we for the the F you know for the first
time we had you know ever with the Q
Prime is and they're just lovely people
first of all they're great human beings
they're fun to be around and they're all
like just so wicked smart and there's so
many of them and every every time
there's a new one we meet in the team I
don't know that's I've never met a group
that wouldn't be your experience with
Dylan street right that's true what
would my experience be just static just
static no no no we'd return most maybe a
call or two but just be like how's it
going doing good great man what do you
want to do sounds great sounds better
than my reps now we take a very
hands-off approach yeah oh I I I could
dig that do your thing Michael guys go
ahead uh it's got to be cool you like
pie pie eating contest and dog star and
dog star and dog star hey talk to me
about I want to get into your like your
favorite band fans of all time and what
like inspired you or like when when you
were growing up what were you listening
to like I like a lot of [__] across the
board you know I could say oh what up
but I could also say uh depesh mode I
Love The Cure I love kind of alternative
stuff I love Pearl Jam I like them all
over but what would you say you know
were your influencers for for you know
the band and just you know in general we
are all three come from totally
different neighborhoods on this one
really yeah well
musical dog star Vin
diagram and so here's the Brett color
Brett well I have a couple colors
because I have colors as a singer colors
as a guitar player and then colors as a
songwriter I love I think I love these
guys if they're as genuine as I'm seeing
then this is uh this is pretty good I
want to be in this band can I just do
something like a rattle or something
share the colors go ahead Brett uh well
okay
so growing up as a kid I was more into
the song I didn't know anything about
playing music yet or playing instruments
yet so I loved Elon John Billy Joel like
the AM radio what was happening in the
70s and uh all that all that stuff was
just I just listened for good songs I
didn't know I was but I you know just
like anybody I'm drawn to a good song um
poppy you know catchy song and then I
started getting into guitar and
so that became like okay how do I get as
good as possible on the guitar that
became like Rush de leopard wow I love
Death Leopard and also you two so I was
like you I was all over the place I had
Iron Maiden in there I was trying to
like learn the guitar like properly
learn the guitar so I could get in a
band someday and MTV was on and I just
wanted to do that so those guys kind of
got me primed as far as like learning
the guitar and then singing I got thrown
into because our our band the singer was
awful and people kept going your
background vocals are better than his
lead vocals you got to sing and so they
just kind of forced me into being a
singer when I was like 17 wow and then
and then I started writing songs after
all that it just kind of all just
happened so all three of those things
and as a singer I don't really think
about anybody other than people that
have passion you know like like again
Elton John Tom Petty people that's when
they sing you believe them that's all I
don't care if they're rock or if they
country you know um John Denver who was
who was on my radio when I pulled into
your driveway um so just believability
passion all that so that's my long short
answer that's a good answer Rob he's
just going to go rat thank you mik drop
I thought de leopard was was deaf like
they couldn't hear like it was like de
leopard I didn't know it was de I mean
for I also thought Jimmy Hendricks sang
excuse me well like kiss this guy so I I
which would have been fine yeah which is
fine not the sky I didn't know you know
um you know it's when you're a little
kid you're hearing all these things
right and you the first time you hear a
radio so I guess I'm a bit older so I
for me it was you know the the British
Invasion was the first thing I heard you
know and then I realized that they were
playing was all this great American
black music and blues and mtown and and
all that stuff what it was like will
Dixon or FATZ Domino or all that all
those great you know James Brown and so
I kind of went back and forth trying to
find the blueprints of what the British
guys were doing you what the Rolling
Stones were doing what the Beatles were
doing like who I was looking on the
album I was like the first albums that
weren't really written by them they were
covering stuff but they were covering
American artists you know and they were
covering like American you know black
artists they were covering people that
we never knew you know or I didn't know
where they were from you know obscure
places that weren't they weren't famous
but these all the way across the pond
they're making these people they were
like tribute to them so I kind of got
back and forth and then I just got like
kind of like you I got obsessed just
with everything that sort of British
like moving on into the 70s and the 80s
and depes mode and the Cure and all all
that stuff and and know I think you know
the Beatles were it for me you know you
saw that and it was something different
you know be prior to that you know I
didn't Elvis Presley so much so maybe
because I wasn't a 15-year-old girl but
I didn't I didn't I didn't get that like
I understood it but um I got him later
yeah it's I'm like wow you have to go
backwards like like with Frank Sinatra
you're like oh that's the stuff my
parents would listen to like Frank like
elepant Gerald Billy Holiday then you go
backwards and you hear that and you go
oh my God that's like so good I mean
it's not what I was into right but but
he sort of come back to that as you get
older but I'm kind of like you I just
sort of and then Brett as well like I
love you know I love all those singer
songwriters and I love Cat Stevens James
Taylor I don't really care if it's
classical or Jazz I like a good Melody a
good like just it's just a feeling of a
song crossby Stills a Nash all that
stuff but I it's but isn't it fun to go
try to discover the blueprints of things
like I've been obsessed with that lately
because I think we got a lot of stuff
got buried like like maybe we didn't get
what we thought we were getting and
maybe or maybe we weren't they just
didn't present those people to us but
there's people that oh no I knew about
those people but I'm like I didn't know
like I want to know like you know yeah
we've heard of Chuck Barry of course but
there's I didn't know that there might
have been a blueprint before him yeah I
was like huh who influenced him yeah
like who the hell was that you know what
I'm saying so I'm going down this Rabbit
Hole of like stuff lately and and it's
just an incredible journey and it's
American and it's and it's it's
incredible so that's great great I I I
wonder why the British kids like got all
that I like how did they get all that
and maybe some of us didn't maybe that's
maybe that was the radio they were
Hearing in England or something we got
Chicago brother we got Chicago you know
what I mean were they just hearing
different radio than we were hearing I
don't I don't know you know yeah I don't
know yeah but Koo uh I I I'll start with
like the being like 1819 and know and a
girlfriend who just said you know you
should listen to this and I was like
what and what was that I said like stuff
now that's kind of like you know but at
the time like this is like
84 83
84 so like hearing Husker do or the
violent fem or Jesus and Mary Chain or
The Clash The Ramones for the first time
yeah CU I hadn't heard that music before
then before I was like 18 17
18 when I heard that I was like yeah so
I I I actually really like a good I love
a fast 44 time pop song that's Rock
whether it's in like in a different
shape like the exploited to me made kind
of pop songs sometimes you know like
dead cities got so much melody in it but
it's still punk rock and the remone have
Melody so I like I like that but I just
love bass guitar and
drums pix the Pixies I can feel a little
bit dude I just saw the Pixies at the
bull with Modest Mouse great great I I
love them yeah I got to hang out with
Frank Black after like what so cool yeah
they're doing a um another tour where
they're just going to play Trump leond
and another album full both so they're
going to be doing that but um those are
Co everybody you're right everybody's so
different but it kind of works it just
works I think that's yeah that's what we
all bring up an important puzzle piece
you know that that we wouldn't be able
to do without the three of us it would
vastly alter the dynamic you know so
there's there's definitely we cover the
Spectrum I think between the three of us
yeah um we went to do this thing the
other day at amiba records where we're
picking out heard know and keo's got the
box set of Vagner you know what well
never heard the you know the ring cycle
from front to back so I was like oh okay
I'm at amoeba that's what you do so I'm
going to spend seven hours and listen to
the ring the rings that was my
grandfather's favorite was it he loved
that the Rings he I never listened to it
I should yeah so I'm like yeah yeah
someone do that but anyway wow what are
they called rug no Norman strong andan I
don't there's three names right the the
Rings maybe there's five I don't know um
you know the I have to at least mention
it we're getting to the end here um but
this is the end this is the end do you
like the doors my only friend the end
and he walked on down the hallway and he
saw Dan Thompson right there let me ask
you this uh you know we talk about
Mental Health on this podcast and it
helps so many people and I I didn't even
know I was getting into it it sort of
just happened I started being a little
more vulnerable and you know
self-deprecating and real so I'm just
like curious what you guys do for your
mental health I mean um you know I go to
therapy and uh you know I work on myself
constantly but is
is is it playing music is your therapy
is it exercise is your therapy is it all
of it or do you guys also do therapy or
whatever what do you do to kind of calm
yourself I guess I'll go I I feel that
I've learned
um that if I be more loving to other
people that it makes me
better that's beautiful yeah I feel the
same way and it's amazing how you don't
even that realization doesn't it doesn't
happen when you're younger all the time
sometimes it takes you years to sort of
go wow just being a good person is
enough you know just to
to because if you feel like that's
coming to you and it's not like
artificial like I'm just G to try to be
you know it's not honestly like you
don't want to go that doesn't always
work if if you know someone it depends
you know but I just feel that
uh CU it's almost what you want for
yourself or what we'd like to have but
it does have a healing I mean there is a
lot of healing and love you know I dig
it I I like it
Brett
therapy for sure no I think uh I think
songwriting you know writing in general
can be therapeutic I think um some my
songs that lyrically I get to revisit
nightly so that's kind of cool to to
continually check in on those feelings
and things like that so that's that's
important but the number one thing I do
to to chill and to get away from it all
is I I like to be social and is going to
make me sound like a raging alcoholic
but I love nothing more than sitting at
a bar with friends and just bullshitting
and just having a drink and talk talking
that's like my favorite world just
current
affairs the history what might what's to
come just and then just take it in the
room new people wandering around and so
that's kind of like my favorite thing to
do is just call somebody and go hey you
want to go to the smok house let's go to
The Smokehouse and get a beer and some
cheesy garlic bread and look at people
and talk like so and luckily I got aot
people on tap that are like yeah let's
go right now so yeah that's like my
favorite thing to do but see my
therapist thinks that I like to do that
all the time and be around people but
being alone is cuz I don't want to be
alone
and so there's some kind of there's some
kind of I don't know what that is but
it's like yo I love having friends over
and I love the love and I love the
conversations and then why do you have
to go we're pack I guess I'm just here
by myself playing bass guitar you can
learn a lot by being alone like during
the I thought you going to say dummy by
being a dummy remember that one you
could learn a lot from a dummy like but
during the pandemic a lot a lot of us
were alone you know and not necessarily
or with the partner or not but I'm just
saying even with the partner you know
two of you or one of you or but we were
alone and so a lot of people learned a
lot about you know you read these
stories like during the pandemic there
were so many people got divorced well
you know what maybe that was good maybe
that was good they realized they were
with the wrong person you know or you
know or you know or you people
discovered things like I learned to cook
or I learned I didn't know this about
myself because they were all the
[__] was shut down and you were sort
of forced it's sort of like a odd forced
meditation you were like forced to sit
in a [__] in a room for 2 years and not
really leave the house and you're like
oh my God all this stuff and then you
know you either learn to like yourself
or you like you know what this is okay
this is okay to be alone and it's
there's so many things you can do and uh
you don't need all the all the [__]
outside and there's nothing wrong with
it like Brett said that's the great to
go out and do all that I agree with them
but it's also nice to be comfortable
with yourself and U so that was kind of
a weird you know what's weird though is
like uh it was almost okay to feel alone
during that time it's like well
everybody else is also feeling alone too
so this is cool I'm alone I'm alone and
it's but then all of a sudden the
pandemic's over and you're like I'm
still alone anyway K back to you no no
uh would you say that you know is is you
know something that helps you for your
mental health and and all that kind of
stuff yeah I guess if I'm um I
internalize a lot of things and so I try
to find spaces where I can just um and
this is something I probably yeah anyway
um sit and think sit and feel be uh
quiet um if I have to work something out
what am I feeling you know I like to
yeah just sit think stare out the window
maybe jump on a
motorcycle um and yeah just kind of ask
myself what do you thinking why you
feeling that if it's distressful like
why what do you want what's going on um
um you usually get to the bottom of it
when you're doing that yeah sometimes or
I see the bottom I'm like well okay you
know I'll I'll I'll just lean I'll lean
into my coping mechanisms or how how to
be like um and I think uh probably
coming out of that is either is some
form of communication communicating it
to yourself you know or um communicating
it to someone else which could be
sharing or looking for like you're
you're talking about therapy so having a
reflection or someone to listen who
might have um you know uh different
perspectives we'll call it professional
perspectives tools um but yeah so for me
it's like internalize and then work on
the communication and um and then if
it's like really like you know personal
like your childhood or you know what do
you feel about your mother or you know
family or stuff from the past you know
if you're dealing like you know for me
it's like intimacy good thing so it's
like okay how do I work on that how do I
you acknowledge it yeah yeah acknowledge
it and see and look at it and what does
that unpack you know but that's a
therapeutic process but if it's just get
through the [__] day sit be quiet
maybe jump on a motorcycle hang out
maybe have a glass of wine isn't it
weird like when you're young like you're
talking about that childhood stuff it's
almost like like you look at a picture
it's like you're almost not the same
that's not the same person but you it is
clearly it is it is but it's like wait a
minute is was that me or is that the
same person and then you realize oh it's
different now but I know what you mean
about like well then you get into
Behavioral Systems and wiring and like
and then we just we could we would have
to do another Insight yeah inside of
your bra but actually but that's kind of
what you're doing Michael I mean you're
going this road this journey of what
inside of you and sharing it so yeah you
know I think the vulnerability of that
you know I think vulnerability is
probably a key thing isn't it yeah I
think it's if if you're not showing
yourself and you're you shouldn't be
preaching it you shouldn't be telling
people how what they should be doing if
you're not also at least acknowledging
it right I don't know really it depends
on the depends on the context right you
don't need your therapist to start
crying in front of you or to tell you
about something right that's true that
would be kind of odd on that would not
be Prof I had a therapist once uh say
you mind if I eat this Subway sandwich
in front of you I'm just really hungry I
haven't eaten it was when you did in
person I go yeah that was my last
session but have you had one fall asleep
[__] is this have you no but oh could
you imagine so Bor with me I told I had
one therapist
say why you being a
[__] and I go what and then I go I
guess I was kind of a [__] that's
called tough love yeah it was do you
ever have that like a I I was I had an
acting teacher once in college said you
got to get rid of that that that judging
eye that's always talking to you and
looking at you and if you can shatter I
think there's four the ID the ego and
the super ego if you can shatter that
old school paradigms yeah Robert with
the old school old schol old school old
school paradig but you can't get how do
you get rid of that like you ever that
conversation like shut the [__] up like
that voice that judging thing if you can
shatter that thing but then again is it
even can you even do that I think for a
lot of actors they're always like not a
lot of actors but artists and sometimes
that voice thing gets in the way like
you need to [__] shoot that thing
with a
shotgun and then get it out I I agree
but I also like I don't think I'm cool
enough to just
internalize oh you like you're just how
you inter have you always been like that
where you can just sit there and be I
don't know how the F that's a gift can
you do that Brett can you just sit and
shut the [__] up and internalize no I my
girlfriend says shees says you never
stop talking you come home and I'm like
well I have to talk to somebody and you
live here so sorry that's your job part
of your job now so you can you can leave
if you don't like it but I you can talk
to us she's like don't you need to rest
your voice for the
show the tour this is going to air soon
so how long does the tour go on for 17
days 17 more days yeah do you wanted to
continue what if they say you want to
extend it would you do it it'll be
Christmas we started our Tour on
December 3rd through December
20 21st I think do you love it do you
love the traveling I love it we love it
I love it I love being on a bus with
these these crazy cats I like playing
shows yeah I like the the randomness
every every day something different
different city different people
different restaurants different looks
just you never get the same thing twice
and we don't know what's going to like
we don't know what's going to happen and
then there then playing is always great
and we have really good support yeah
around us people we just have love it
huh we just have great and a great tour
manager great management great s you
know everybody's just so nice you know
we got great fans though we really do
they're yeah that's and they've evolved
with us I think um it seems like now
there's
seems like now they're they're listening
more if that makes any sense I think I
think I think they're a little more like
listening and I mean maybe we've all
matured a bit together but um you know
when we were younger it was a little
more Reckless and crazy and people more
noisier and screaming and jumping around
and now it's more like it seems like
people have a real interest in the in
what we're doing musically more so
than and the ages are all over the place
too like there's like you young all the
way it's a different and there's more
guys that's a good thing right well
there used to be yeah it's just it's a
and there's there's you'll see some you
it's it's just a different yeah we just
great and we've also had a very uh a
couple of nights where we've been
introduced to some people and it was
their first concert ever like some
teenagers and some some young kids cool
and and I always take that like we
better not suck tonight like we got a
heavy responsibility tonight guys like
this is that girl's first concert ever
you know and she's going to someone's
going to ask her in 25 years what was
your first concert andar and they were
great I hope that's what she says yeah
ex was it what it was a Pie Contest
contest and dog star guys this has been
awesome I I I never have had Blue Ribbon
Blue Ribbon paps Blue Ribbon yeah you
know maybe that's
from Yes uh hi no no no no don't tell me
it's from the um oh my God no don't
don't no no no no wait wait we wait I'm
not saying no no Dennis Hopper it's
Dennis Hopper in oh my God Frederick
Elms is the
cinematographer and and what's the name
of that movie because it's so good and
it's called blue velvet velvet nice hin
[__] that [__] pops Blue
Ribbon Isabella
rosalini David Lynch oh who's your
favorite actor ever not going there
never would who's your top one top 10
give one uh inspiring um Robert
dairo Taxi Driver people have said that
before too people like that's the movie
what about you that's is it pet wow got
to meet him K and I met him once I'm
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you I'm
sorry he's getting excited I don't have
a go I don't have an answer yet go ahead
Rob
oh man Daniel Day Lewis I love him and I
also you know I maybe I'll get I love
Albert Brooks people there's a
documentary on Al Brooks now I got to
watch that he's the most relaxed yeah
something about him and drive are you
kidding me it's frightening how good he
is in that movie yeah and uh oh no I
didn't see that I saw dri Defending Your
I mean def I mean come on he's just I
mean I there's something about him that
I just can't stop I just love him but
you know Daniel de Lewis you know of
course toiro Oldman Merl stre Nicholson
yeah lawence
Olivia guys this has been a joy I don't
want to take any more time this has been
unbelievable thank you I I really got to
know you guys and I and I appreciate you
coming in and thanks for allowing me to
be inside you and coming over the house
it means a lot thank you cheers man
thank you it's been fun thanks
bye I loved it I I loved it I was
thinking what could we cut and I asked
you about it and you were like well
nothing really it's all good and I trust
you because I normally I have to cut out
when you say certain stuff you know but
this one you didn't say just kidding
well you know what's funny is I um
normally you say that one thing we
always have to cut out but this time
well I just get bored sometimes um with
myself and so I'm like ah cut that whole
thing if it doesn't move the story if
it's redundant if it's slow or if it's
an uncomfortable moment or if it affects
the this one felt like it floated I
thought it was a good episode good uh
and is the season to be giving I want to
uh give a shout out to the many fine
nonprofits that I work with in love the
Ronald McDonald House of Los Angeles
food onf foot.org if you want to donate
um the animal rescue mission shout out
to my friend Shir asro who saves so many
animals so many doggies and uh I love
them um echos of hope.org for um Foster
Youth and um some great nonprofits that
really are tremendous
and um serve La little shout out to
Hower Mr Paul Hower oh yeah yeah I went
to his event and that's it I hope you
guys uh have an awesome holiday Bryce I
hope you have an awesome holiday my
friend but before we do that should we
read some of the most important people
in my life yeah let's do it top tier
patrons here we go couldn't do it
without
you
lilisa Nancy D lean Kristen little Lisa
Yukiko I said little Lisa you did Jill e
but I said her first Brian H Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike E Lon supro 99 more San Diego M
Chad W Leanne P Maddie s Belinda n Dave
hello Dave hole I love Dave Hall how
many times have you heard me say Dave
Hall Bryce uh a lot great Sheila G Brad
d Ray had Tabitha T Tom n Talia M Betsy
D ranne andc Corey K Deb Nexon Michelle
a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey M Eugene and
Leah Corey Angela F Mel s Christine s
Erica H Shane R Andrew M Amanda R Kevin
e you know now that I have a son and we
read every night I have to start reading
again out loud and I don't like it
get I'll take over well you know it's uh
maybe I'll read him Patron names to go
to sleep I'm sure that would put him to
sleep no it wouldn't it' give him energy
Stephanie K Joor L jam and J lean J Luna
R Mike F Stone H Brian L Jules M Kendall
L Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Kaylee J
Brian a Ashley F Mari and Louise L Romeo
the band Frank B Jen T Nikki L April r
Andy s jdw oral P Ginger
Insomniac Rachel D Melissa H Nick W
Stephanie and Evan Charlene a Don G
Jenny B from the you know what's cool is
we started Patron maybe almost three or
four years ago I remember it was in
December and so a lot of the folks that
were around back then are still around
today which is rad yeah you guys are
just uh so incredible and you're so
important to me and it's fun funny when
I'm writing those little notes in the
boxes that I send you guys every week or
every a couple months uh I always think
what am I going to say and then I just
speak from the heart I'm just like you
know how much it means to me and how you
know amazing they are and like they've
heard it but it's like you
know there's only so much you could say
but there's the love is there and um but
they they've stuck around it's pretty
incredible I always think oh they're
going to leave me they're going to leave
me they're going to you know and they
people have lives and they have jobs and
they you know and I'm so surprised that
they're even there and that they just
like the podcast and they uh yeah they
show up it's cool they show up man you
guys show up and uh as long as you're
here I'm here so thanks um so I guess
that's it so have a wonderful holiday uh
be good to yourself I usually say that
at the end of the episode but um you
know and sometimes the holidays are
tough if you've lost someone um I know a
few of my friends are going to be
without their parents or you know my
friend Al is going to be without her
father for the holidays and she just
lost him and it's really tough and you
know it's just uh it could be tough and
for a lot of people and um but there's a
light there is not to be uh profoundly
cliche but there there is a light at the
end of the tunnel there is this is life
man it's it's waves it's you hit the
bottom and you come back up for air and
then there's beautiful weather in front
of you and then all of a sudden uh
[__] [__] storm hit you and you just
got to get through it and love your
friends hang around people that you
enjoy people that don't bring you down
and uh thank you Bryce for being here
all my love to you and Logan Beckham yep
and love to
Ryan uh Taz um and Jason to you to you
my friend my editing friend so from the
Hollywood Hills and Hollywood California
I'm Michael
rosenbom I'm Bryce uh we love you guys
and again be good to yourself I'll I'll
see you very very
[Music]
soon